[Musique]
dans 20 ans dans 30 ans il sera trop
tard si notre industrie se développe au
même rythme si nous ne prenons pas garde
dès maintenant bref si nous n'organisons
pas notre avenir dans trente ans nous
manqueront d'eau dans trente ans les
rivières du nord super polluer ne
recueilleront plus que l'eau plus que
salle des égouts ajoutez à cela que les
ressources naturelles souterraines
seront insuffisantes pour satisfaire nos
besoins alors il faudra sans doute
employer les grands moyens et envisager
de dessaler l'eau de mer
[Musique]
inexorablement le nord aura soif
c'est en gros ce que prévoit le livre
blanc publié il y a deux ans par l'
agence du bassin artois-picardie
[Musique]
cependant ne voyons pas trop les choses
en noir rassurons nous les solutions on
les trouvera sans doute car nous ne
saurions nous passer de
[Musique]
l'eau à la source de toute vie sans eau
il n'y a plus de vie plus de vie des
plantes plus de vie les animaux plus de
vie du sol et là le désert et l'image du
monde sans eau or le désert encore un
peu de vie c'est parce qu'il ya de l'eau
dans l'atmosphère de l'humidité
atmosphérique sinon on aurait pas de vie
du tout donc l'eau et la base
fondamentale de toute existence
végétales animales et par là de
l'existence de l'homme justement quel a
été le comportement de l'homme vis-à-vis
de l'eau au fil des siècles au fil des
âges des civilisations est bien l'homme
a commencé à domestiquer l'eau il ya
bien longtemps il a domestiqué l'eau par
des travaux de utilisation des
inondations ça a été en mesure pottas me
et en egypte utilisation des innovations
du nil il a fallu faire des travaux
astronomiques pour en prévoir le retour
et ça a été la base du calendrier il a
fallu ensuite dirigé l'innovation et de
la direction l'innovation n'est passer
progressivement à l'irrigation cette
irrigation d'ailleurs aboutit finalement
à des destructions de sol par excès de
sel est aujourd'hui les bases première
de l'agriculture salle où a débuté
l'agriculture intensive ya cinq ou six
mille ans sont des déserts de la
mésopotamie à l'iran donc l'eau est un
instrument à double tranchant il faut
savoir le manier le mammy à bon escient
sinon ça peut être la meilleure mais
aussi la pire des choses mal utilisé
[Musique]
pendant longtemps nous avons donc
considéré lot commun dans gratuit du
ciel au cours des âges il n'est pas une
ville qui n'ait voulu sans jolivet de
splendides jeux d'eau on a célébré les
fontaines de rome paris et fiers à juste
titre de ce spectacle du palais de
chaillot symbole même de l'eau à
profusion de l'eau qui ne coûte rien de
l'eau elle a regardé
partout canaliser l'eau a jailli
rebondissant sur les vasques vaporisant
ces gouttelettes sous un rayon de soleil
complice l'eau les poètes les écrivains
non célébrée l'eau claire et limpide des
sources locales mais mystérieuse des
marécages l'eau est même devenu proverbe
lorsque quelque chose est évident tout
devient clair comme de l'eau de roche
seulement voilà l'eau de roche et de
plus en plus rares et de moins en moins
clair elle une façon très générale l'eau
vient peu à peu à manquer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'eau vient à manquer en fait l'eau
manque déjà plus ou moins selon les
régions considérées selon les saisons 1
était un peu sec et ce sont les
lamentations des nantis de nos régions
développées des était toujours sec un
net recul de la végétation dû à de
multiples facteurs l'incapacité
technique à trouver de l'eau et une
certaine indifférence des pays plus
développés plus avancée et la sécheresse
prend cet aspect lamentable
des milliers d'hommes et de bêtes
agglutinés autour des dernières sources
non tari la vraie sécheresse la voici
c'est celle que connaissent actuellement
les pays du sahel des milliers de morts
bêtes et gens et fort peu d'espoir d'en
sortir à court terme
si l'on se penche sur une carte du
réseau hydrographique composant le
bassin artois-picardie on est très vite
amené à faire plusieurs constatations un
ce secteur est situé à cheval sur la
ligne de partage des eaux entre le
bassin de la seine et la grande plaine
de l'europe du nord ouest où coulent les
secouer leur 1/2 dans ce bassin
artois-picardie la dimension des cours
d'eau est petit le plus grand étant
incontestablement la fom 3 chaque cours
d'eau constitue à lui seul un petit
bassin indépendants 4 un facteur d'unité
apparaît cependant le sous sol sur plus
des trois quarts du bassin sur des
dizaines de mètres d'épaisseur les
terrains son crayon et perméable la
craie joue donc le rôle de réservoir
naturel sous la quasi-totalité de la
région les avantages sont certains l'eau
de pluie s'infiltre en le ruissellement
est faible les risques d'inondation
minimes sauf peut-être dans la vallée de
la sambre et le boulonnais lawn où
l'érosion a été importante laissant à
vif des terrains généralement
imperméable
si l'on survole cette région une autre
constatation s'impose aux cours d'eau
naturels sont venus s'ajouter des cours
d'eau artificiels les canaux dans le
bassin artois-picardie ce réseau
artificielle est particulièrement dense
très vite le peu de relief de la région
a incité nomme à canaliser les rivières
et à les faire communiquer les canaux
sont apparus dès le xviie siècle et
c'est en 1810 que le bassin de la seine
et la région du nord ont été mis en
communication par l'ouverture du canal
de saint-quentin
dernière étape de cette canalisation
la liaison à grand gabarit dunkerque
valenciennes artères économiquement
indispensable
actuellement la plus importante voie
d'eau du bassin
seuls quelques rivières côtières sont
restés indépendante sur le plan de
l'hydraulique il en est ainsi de la
liane de loti et pour quelques temps
encore de la canche cela dit le
ressources en eau du bassin sont elles
suffisantes la rive une heure tant fait
une richard stallman riche en eau
d'abord parce qu'il pleut beaucoup et
ensuite parce que son sous sol contient
des formé de roches calcaires qui
emmagasine des quantités considérables
d'eau par conséquent normalement la
région du nord devrait être une région
où les ressources en eau sont abondantes
en fait ces ressources en eau sont
insuffisantes s'avère en tout cas
insuffisantes du fait de la très forte
industrialisation et de la très forte
urbanisation de cette région du nord pas
de calais et on sait on a pu calculer
par exemple que les ressources
permettent
en année normale est en période d'étiage
c'est à dire à la période de plus basses
ressources en eau permettent
l'utilisation à peu près d'un mètre cube
par jour et par habitant en moyenne mais
ceci tout compris
or si chacun d'entre nous sur le plan
privé n'utilise pas un mètre cube par
jour et par habitant tunis même beaucoup
moins
l'industrie elle utilise les quantités
considérables d'eau or il faut savoir
que du fait de cette intense
urbanisation et c'est intense
industrialisation c'est pas un mètre
cube par jour et par habitant quand on
utilise mais c'est plus de 3 mètres
cubes par jour et par habitant en
moyenne ceux ci tout compris
industrialisation et ressources et
utilisation publique
autrefois la flandre était réputé pour
ses moulins à vent actuellement chef
d'oeuvre en péril on s'efforce de les
restaurer en attendant peut-être crise
de l'énergie obligeant d'en tirer à
nouveau partie sinon quichotte voulait
engager une nouvelle bataille il
pourrait tout aussi bien défier les
châteaux d'eau partout ils ont surgi
véritable témoin de l'urbanisation du
développement du consort le château
d'eau c'est la preuve de la venue de
l'eau courante de l'abandon des puits
des fontaines communal c'est aussi
malheureusement la fin des pompes à main
des coins de rue c'est à l'évidence même
l'organisation de la distribution de
l'eau c'est la preuve incontestable que
l'eau est partout à la disposition de
tous
[Musique]
seulement voilà encore faut-il savoir se
servir de l'eau dans une société marquée
par une industrialisation et une
urbanisation croissante
[Musique]
[Rires]
chaque mètre cube d'eau et utilisait
plusieurs fois ce qui revient à dire que
cette eau est donc salies et sally
exagérément ce qui entraîne une
pollution considérable de toutes les
ressources en eau aussi bien d'ailleurs
des autres surfaces et que même à
l'heure actuelle des eaux de la nappe
phréatique et ceci est beaucoup plus
grave les autres surfaces il faut savoir
sont
pollués à peu près sur toute la région
est pollué de façon extrêmement intensif
c'est la région au point de vue au la
plus polluée de france les rivières du
nord sont à peu près tout pollué dans
leur totalité de leur parcours sauf dans
la petite partie supérieure qui
correspond à leurs sources
et en ce qui concerne la nappe
phréatique et bien toute la zone
correspondant au sud de l'île et dans la
région de est déjà en cours de pollution
extrêmement inquiétante
[Musique]
en france on estime que c'est en 1964
que pour la première fois on s'est
préoccupé de mener une vraie politique
de l'eau à la base de cette politique la
loi du 12 décembre 64 une loi qui
prévoyait l'installation progressive
d'organismes régionaux destinés à
étudier coordonnées mettre en oeuvre
toute action relative à rendre
compatibles les ressources et les
besoins en eau les agences financières
de bassins elles furent installés en
il s'agit d'établissements publics de
l'état pouvant percevoir des redevances
sur les agents contribuant à la
détérioration de la qualité de l'eau
effectuant des prélèvements ou modifiant
le régime général des eaux en fait l'une
des premières tâches des agences était
de faire ressentir à l'ensemble des
utilisateurs la nécessité de la
solidarité
une des premières préoccupations de
lagence de bassar pro picardie fut de
prévoir les besoins en eau régionaux et
surtout de savoir jusqu'à quelle date
les ressources naturelles seraient
suffisants
jusqu'à la fin du siècle
on doit y arriver avec nos ressources
actuelles
en économisant bien l'eau
en la mobilisant
et en stockant l'hiver
celle qui sinon s'écoulerait dandin dans
les crues des rivières ensuite il faudra
sans doute passer ou vers la fin du
siècle au dessalement d'eau de mer ou à
d'autres types de solutions pour
n'envisage peut-être pas encore
actuellement
donc de l'eau en quantité suffisante
on peut le constater
les efforts avec des efforts il faut
bien le dire avec des efforts et si on
fait ce qu'il faut alors les efforts
sont à faire par par monsieur tout le
monde a partout aussi bien par
l'industriel que par le consommateur
individuel marie laure dans ce domaine à
ce que les mentalités peuvent évoluer à
ce qu'elles peuvent évoluer ce qu'on
peut les inciter à évoluer elles peuvent
elles peuvent évoluer elles doivent le
faire elles doivent le faire parce que
elles n'ont pas beaucoup changé ces
temps derniers on a toujours
l'impression et je m'en suis rendu
compte quand on s'adresse
dans une conférence à
des gens intéressés même est au courant
de ses problèmes que leur première
réaction est de penser bien le problème
de la pollution et des économies d'eau
c'est le problème des autres c'est le
problème des soutes vraiment la
pollution ce sont les gros pollueurs
les questions de pénurie d'eau sont les
gros consommateurs c'est vrai c'est vrai
mais chacun d'entre nous peut faire
quelque chose et doit faire quelque
chose si vous voulez
[Musique]
dans la région nord-pas-de-calais
population et industries sont très
concentrés pour la population on estime
à quelque 230 millions de mètres cubes
le volume des prélèvements effectués
dans les nappes pour la consommation
individuelle de 130 millions de mètres
cubes par habitant cela revient à dire
qu'en moyenne chaque habitant du
nord-pas-de-calais utilise 51 mètres
cubes par an consommation relativement
modeste en comparaison des consommations
enregistrées dans les grandes villes de
france et à l'étranger déjà aux états
unis le consommateur moyen utilise deux
fois plus d'eau que le nordiste les
statisticiens américains estiment que la
consommation individuelle de l'eau
devrait doubler tous les 15 ans
comment expliquer ce faible volume de la
consommation régionale si ce n'est en
raison du retard qu'accuse le parc
immobilier régional en matière
d'équipements sanitaires et ce bien que
95 % des logements soient desservis en
eau potable
[Musique]
ces constatations faites les besoins en
eau à usage domestique reste globalement
relativement stable nous buvons un pour
cent de l'eau que nous consommons et
dans un ménage 13 % du volume d'eau sert
à la vaisselle 13 autres pour cent à la
lessive 70% aux besoins sanitaires
ajoutez à cela l'eau qui arrose votre
jardin ou celle que vous utilisez pour
laver votre voiture
consommation individuelle première
source de gaspillage pour se laver il
faut savoir qu'une touche et plus
économique qu'un bain
et c'est aussi beaucoup plus sain
[Musique]
dès lors que nous utilisons de l'eau
nous devenons des pollueurs cette
pollution individuelles même si elle ne
prend pas les allures spectaculaire des
grosses sources de pollution
industrielle cette pollution domestique
donc est importante pour mener à bien la
lutte contre la pollution individuel les
agences de bassins perçoivent par
l'intermédiaire des communes une
redevance calculée en fonction du nombre
d'habitants vivent en agglomération
c'est ainsi que le consommateur que vous
êtes participe indirectement à
l'installation de canalisations d'égouts
participe aux travaux d'assainissement
ou encore à la construction d'une usine
d'épuration d'eaux usées la solidarité
en matière d'eau c'est tout cela
[Musique]
l'eau produits de consommation c'est la
rançon du développement économique c'est
presque la rançon du progrès
insensiblement l'eau du robinet a pris
mauvais goût et ce alors que l'on nous
expliquer que l'eau du robinet était
bonne à boire limpide sans bactéries
traité ici au chlore et là à l'ozone
instinctivement les consommateurs que
nous sommes se sont méfiés de cette eau
presque fabriqués alors mû par une sorte
d'instinct de conservation nous nous
sommes retrouvés sur les eaux en
bouteille il y a quinze ans au minéral
réservé aux traitements médicaux pour
les reins pour le foie au pour les
rhumatismes maintenant on achète de
l'eau pour boire de l'eau pour voir tout
simplement ainsi sont apparus les maxi
bouteille qui en fait n'ont été inventée
que pour vendre de l'eau dans un
emballage en plastique
le système étant à ce conte absurde que
souvent les fabricants de matières
plastiques ont pris le contrôle de
sociétés exploitant les eaux minérales
et eux pour être bien sûr de vente leurs
bouteilles à jeter dès lors on prend
conscience de l'absurdité d'un tel
système à côté de cette
industrialisation de l'eau potable on
assiste par contre un regain d'intérêt
pour les sources qui jaillissent à la
campagne par familles entières le
dimanche on va faire sa provision d'eau
pour la semaine petit à petit on reprend
conscience de la valeur de l'eau petit à
petit donc en conscients du fait que
l'eau pourraient venir à manquer un jour
l'eau va manquer le va manquer parce que
si nous continuons à nous ils
multipliaient inconsidérément nous les
hommes et si nous continuons à
multiplier inconsidérément à la
production industrielle et
l'urbanisation qui exige beaucoup plus
d'eau que la campagne nous manqueront
certainement d'eau avant la fin du
siècle alors quelle mesure va comprendre
et bien il ya une source d'eau que l'on
envisage c'est la désalinisation de
l'eau de mer la ressource sont très
importantes en attendant votre on
commence à transporter des icebergs au
danemark la transporter en californie en
envisageant transporter des glaces que
l'on traîne dans les océans et que l'on
sait de l'eau douce que l'on déjeune
ensuite l'arrivée ça c'est un capital de
glace limité donc c'est une solution
transitoire est provisoire
la décence de saint-omer exigée quand
ils les considèrent à d'énergie et nous
manquons d'énergie e on envisage
l'énergie atomique mais l'énergie
atomique par ces déchets radioactifs est
pleine de dangers alors on ne sait pas
où nous allons croyez qu'il faut arriver
à une révision déchirante des
conceptions de l'économie ou de la
société pour pouvoir conserver les lots
et il faudra gagner en totale des
conceptions de la société si vous
continuez la croise mans actuel de la
population et de la production
industrielle on sait maintenant qu'un
effondrement total de notre civilisation
dans le courant du siècle prochain
simplement la seule discussion est de
savoir si on aura lieu au début ou à la
fin du siècle par ailleurs nous
considérons le climat actuel de l'europe
du monde comme une donnée de fait et on
a tendance à croire qu'elle est
intangible or nous savons bien que il y
à quelques milliers d'années seulement
les glaciers arrivé jusqu'aux portes de
lyon ou jusqu'aux portes de copenhague
bon est ce qu'il y aura un cycle de
refroidissement nous savons qu'il ya eu
des périodes de pluies abondantes les
pères du désert
vers quelle évolution allons nous alors
nous multiplier inconsidérément et
gâcher loi considère inconsidérément
comme nous faisons ne paraît être une
politique de folie
l'agglomération lille roubaix tourcoing
est l'une des plus denses de france il
n'y a pas si longtemps elle était
alimentée en eau potable par l'eau
souterraine puiser dans une nappe dont
on devait vite s'apercevoir qu'elle
tendait à s'épuiser pas question de
recourir aux eaux de surface aux abords
de l'agglomération ces eaux sont toutes
très pollué pollution due en grande
partie aux industries qui depuis un
siècle et demi se développe dans la
région pour la métropole nord il fallait
donc aller chercher l'eau plus loin plus
loin mais pas trop loin dans une rivière
non polluée et haut débit suffisant
c'est ainsi que fut choisi la lys le
lieu de prélèvement air est en située à
une soixantaine de kilomètres de lille
[Musique]
dans ce réservoir cent mille mètres
cubes d'eau la consommation de notre
population domaine de la population ce
qui concerne la consommation domestique
elle est relativement faible dans notre
région elle est de l'ordre de soixante
dix mètres cubes par an et par habitant
ce qui est de l'ordre de la moitié de la
consommation française à quoi cela tient
probablement conditions atmosphériques
probablement aussi au retard dans le
développement du sanitaire et peut-être
aussi au prix de l'eau qui est
d'ailleurs assez élevé dans notre région
parce que nous devons traiter des eaux
nous devons les élever et nous avons
absolument le talent qu une fois nous
sommes en aucune façon avantagés par
rapport aux autres régions françaises
imprudent de l'eau est sensiblement le
même que celui de paris il ya quand même
une consommation importante qui se fait
sur la communauté urbaine à tel point
qu'on est obligé d'aller chercher de
l'eau un petit peu loin maintenant
alors les ressources sont suffisantes
la puissance des usines actuelles de la
société les eaux du nord et de la régie
communautaire et de 280 mille mètres
cubes jour pour une consommation qui est
de l'ordre de 200 220 mille mètres cubes
jour en moyenne c'est dire tout de même
que nous avons une marge assez faible
parce que là la puissance de 280 mille
mètres cubes jour correspond à toutes
les usines en marché complètement alors
pour augmenter nos ressources et faire
face à l'augmentation de la consommation
il a été créé l' usine d'aire-sur-la-lys
l'usiné hier sur le lycée l'amenée d'eau
à l'agglomération lilloise dont le coût
a été environ 12 milliards et qui sera
complété par le transfert cance lice
lorsque nous disposerons de la
déclaration d'utilité publique pour
pouvoir faire ce travail
voici donc lusine d'aire-sur-la-lys l'un
des plus beaux fleurons de l'équipement
réalisé pour l'agglomération lille
roubaix tourcoing par la communauté
urbaine de lille lusine elle même n'est
qu'un des éléments d'un vaste complexe
extrêmement moderne où les techniques
les plus poussées ont été mises en
application
la station de traitement d'eau potable
de pompage peut actuellement rappelons
le traité cent mille mètres cubes d'eau
par jour le débit pouvant être doublée
dans un très proche délai
[Musique]
tout d'abord chlorés pu décanter l'eau
est ensuite filtrée dans les cuves de
béton remplis de sable ensuite cette eau
sera stérilisé la stérilisation étant
effectuée par l'ozone cet automne à sion
éliminant la plupart des micropolluants
les virus et cetera précisons que
l'ozonation donne à l'eau une légère
teinte bleutée toute cette installation
est en permanente surveillé par
l'électronique
alors vraiment un défaut sur les grands
moteurs de la grille de
le moindre défaut est immédiatement des
scellés le consommateur de lille roubaix
tourcoing ne fera jamais rien
vraisemblablement cette usine est l'une
des pièces maîtresse dans le dispositif
devant assurer de l'eau à
l'agglomération à l'horizon 80 au delà
il faudra aller chercher ailleurs plus
loin encore plus loin mais en observant
certaines règles élémentaires 1 il
faudra renoncer à exploiter
systématiquement toutes les nappes
souterraines sinon on fera disparaître
des rivières 2 il faudra laisser jouer à
certains cours d'eau le rôle naturel de
collecteurs tout en régularisant leur
débit en multipliant les précautions et
en sachant jouer avec les rivières en
les spécialisant on devrait pouvoir
atteindre l'an 2000 en respectant un
équilibre naturel pourtant fragile mais
attention aux fautes attention aux
erreurs car pour certains projets le
barrage sur la canche notamment
l'unanimité a bien du mal à se faire en
fait le projet consiste à faire un
pompage des eaux de la canche mais très
en amont c'est à dire à peu près au
niveau de la ville dédain pour amener
ces eaux par canalisations jusqu'à dans
la région de la métropole nord lille
roubaix tourcoing et pour donc
permettent une amélioration
de l'alimentation en eau de du centre de
la région mais en fait le barrage sur la
canche ne l'améliorent absolument pas du
tout ce système il va barrer un estuaire
pour faire un plan d'eau il sera
essentiellement à usage touristique
aucun pompage aucun prélèvement d'eau ne
se fait dans le barrage lui-même il n'a
par conséquent on n'a rien à voir avec
le pompage et l'alimentation en eau de
la région d'une heure par contre il
risque d'avoir des conséquences
extrêmement néfaste extrêmement même
catastrophiques sur la faune marine et
en particulier sur les poissons de mer
car il faut savoir que les estuaires et
ceci est valable pour l'estuaire de la
canche comme pour tous les estuaires du
monde que c'est au niveau des estuaires
que se fait essentiellement l'élevage
des embryons de poissons les marques des
alevins la plupart des poissons mère
grandissent au niveau des estuaires et
se nourrissent de la production qu'on
appelle production primaire ou
secondaire les micro organismes et les
petits organismes qui croissent et se
développe dans les estuaires et ces
sondes et ses petits organismes que se
nourrissent les poissons de mer
d'ailleurs c'est bien connu du fait que
les poissons les jeunes poissons les
petits poissons sont toujours concentrés
au niveau des estuaires et que pour
cette région là pour cette raison-là la
pêche industrielle est interdite au
niveau des estuaires
[Musique]
jusqu'à présent nous sommes
essentiellement préoccupés de la
consommation individuelle de l'eau avec
cette constatation que faure peuple et
la région n'a pas encore atteint le
seuil limite de la consommation
individuelle il est vrai que par le jeu
du recyclage de l'eau chaque mètre cube
à plusieurs utilisateurs d'un côté de la
consommation individuelle existe la
consommation lié au développement de
l'industrie
la population consomme environ 2300
millions de mètres cubes par an
l'industrie elle tire 320 millions de
mètres cubes d'eau dans les nappes et
600 millions de mètres cubes d'eaux de
surface au total donc près de deux mille
millions de mètres cubes pour une
industrie qui représente les neuf
dixièmes et laine peignée la moitié du
charbon extrait en france le tiers du
sucre de la teinture et des engrais
azotés le quart de la bière et de
l'acier le cinquième de l'électricité
thermique et du pathé carton
il
mais
et
au total donc des industries de
transformation grosses utilisatrices dos
d industrie extrêmement polluantes la
seconde bataille que l'on doit engager
dans le bassin artois-picardie est donc
bien la bataille de l'eau propre
vassa très peuplée au moins au nord de
l'artois avec la région lilloise le
bassin minier
très industrialisée aussi
et dans lequel les pollutions ne sont
pas très diluées donc parce qu'il ya pas
énormément d'eau lorsqu'on lit le livre
blanc de l' agence de bassin s'aperçoit
qu'on en est arrivé à une certaine
spécialisation des cours d'eau alors
c'est peut-être un peu affolant de
spécialiser des cours d'eau c'est fait a
priori ou c'est le fait d'une politique
à long terme c'est le fait d'une
politique
mais cette spécialisation c'est à dire
classe et les cours d'eau en trois
catégories des cours d'eau sur lesquels
les efforts devront être rapides et
importants et des cours d'eau de
troisième catégorie sur lesquels les
efforts seront moins rapides en un
premier temps sané qui vaut pas du tout
abandonné ces derniers à leur triste
sort et à considérer qu'ils sont des
égouts ça je crois qu'il faut bien le
dire clairement et avec force ça n'est
pas une politique du pire c'est
simplement une priorité parce qu'on se
rend compte que l'on ne peut pas faire
le même effort partout que un franc
investi sera beaucoup plus utile ou
utile à plus grand nombre d'habitants
s'il est investi au dans le bassin
pendant une comparaison quand vous
sortez de votre vin commencez pas par
vous essuyer les pieds faute de quoi
quand vous aurez essuyé les pieds ils
seront à nouveau mouillé par l'eau qui
vous dégringolera du dow ont commencé
par huissier la tête basse et ce qu'il
faut faire semble-t-il en commençant par
épuré le haut des cours d'eau
en spécialisant les cours d'eau l'
agence de bassin estime que l'on peut
mieux surveiller l'évolution de la
pollution quitte à condamner
provisoirement une rivière à devenir un
véritable égout à ciel ouvert c'est
notamment le cas de la deûle qui est
trop connu malheureusement des lillois
pour ce qui concerne l'industrie les
actions à mener sont nombreuses et
variées on ne peut envisager de trouver
de solution miracle de solution passe
par tout résoudre le problème de
l'industrie chimique est déjà
suffisamment complexe des effluents
provenant de certaines fabrications est
temps par nature assez peu
biodégradables
pour en savoir davantage sur les
incidences du développement de la chimie
sur l'état des eaux dans le nord nous
avons envisagé le cas du numéro un de la
chimie dans la région jean kullmann
cette firme emploie 3200 personnes dans
ces établissements régionaux dont les
plus importants sont situés à la
madeleine en bordure de la deûle
précisément pour ses besoins de
fabrication lusine pompe environ
4800 mètres cubes d'eau dans la deûle et
utilise également les ressources d'un
forage particulier
lusine possède son propre système
d'épuration à système qui permet dur est
de distribuer dans l' usine dit qualité
d'eau différents bien entendu la qualité
de l'eau de la deûle pose de nombreux
problèmes à tel point qu'il faut
utiliser de l'eau potable pour fabriquer
l'eau déminéralisée qui devra alimenter
les chaudières
nous avons deux catégories de résidus r
d obéir aux sorte simplement à peu
réchauffées qui représentent 90% nos
rejets et des eaux qui peuvent contenir
des produits utilisés dans notre usine
est que nous appellerons sous les eaux
résiduaires ce sont surtout les produits
minéraux qui n'apportent donc pas de
pollution organique dans la gueule
mais peut arriver qu'il y ait une
certaine pollution nous surveillons de
très près la qualité de saison que nous
avons
du personnel au laboratoire de
s'occupper permanent sans surveillance
de la qualité de nos jeunes et aussi de
la qualité de l'eau que nous comprenons
dans l'adle pour pouvoir l'utiliser donc
votre souci et de polluer le moins
possible et je pense que ça nécessite la
mise au point
l'installation de stations d'épuration
d'eau station de recyclage
à chaque fois que nous montons une
installation nouvelle nous essayons de
prévoir au maximum
la purification des rejets ou le
recyclage des eaux résiduaires pourrait
couper des rejets
[Musique]
pour toute installation nouvelle nous
commençons par étudier le projet et par
et prévoir des installations pour
traiter les eaux résiduaires ou les
recycler pour des installations plus
anciennes nous avons un programme
d'investissement important
qui est approuvée par l' agence de
bassin et qui va nous permettre
d'améliorer la qualité des eaux dans
l'avenir nous avons un programme en 1975
et 1976 qui se monte à 2 millions 400
mille francs en 1975 et trois millions
quatre cent mille francs en 1976
nous avons deux organismes principaux
qui assurent la surveillance ce sont ces
d'une part les établissements classés
qui au stade du projet avant la
construction vérifie que nous avons bien
pris toutes les précautions nécessaires
pour traiter nos projets et d'autre part
en agence de bassin qui par un système
de taxes et de subventions incite les
industriels et les collectivités locales
à traiter leur zoo le mieux possible
[Musique]
autre industrie particulièrement
implanté sur la métropole l'industrie
textile une industrie qui voit beaucoup
car pour faire une tonne de draps il
faut environ 200 mètres cubes d'eau on
prévoyait d'augmenter le nombre de mini
station d'épuration dans cette industrie
textile or il semble bien que l'on se
soit heurté à plus d'une difficulté tout
d'abord parc implanté au coeur des
villes les entreprises ne disposent pas
forcément de beaucoup de place pour
installer leurs propres dispositifs de
traitement d'eaux résiduelles la
solution viendra peut-être de la
restructuration de cette industrie
textile que certains prévoient déjà
deuxième problème un problème technique
qui restent à résoudre le traitement des
eaux de teinturerie ne semble pas encore
tout à fait au point cela dit l' agence
de bassin incitent toutefois les
industriels à s'équiper une vingtaine
d'entreprises vont recevoir une aide
substantielle dans le courant des mois à
venir et parmi celles-ci l'industrie
textile n'a pas été oublié c'est sans
doute au coeur de la métropole que l'on
peut prendre conscience de la dimension
internationale du problème de l'eau les
rivière coulant vers la belgique nos
voisins d'outre-quiévrain devrait
bénéficier de nos efforts industriels
français et belge suivent également dans
la même nappe encore faudrait-il qu'ils
puissent également or si l'industrie
français semblent avoir stabilisé le
niveau de ces prélèvements il semble
bien que la croissance des prélèvements
belges continuent à faire baisser
dangereusement le niveau de l'anah une
politique communautaire de l'eau est
elle impossible à mener à cette question
il conviendrait de répondre très
rapidement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
après la métropole c'est la zone du
littoral allant de boulogne à dunkerque
qui devrait se développer plus
rapidement au cours des prochaines
décennies un pôle essentiel bien sûr
dunkerque fos-sur-mer bien avant la
lettre dunkerque où toutes les
industries commanderont une consommation
d'eau de plus en plus importe cette
industrie lourde ce sera la sidérurgie
bien sûr mais aussi la chimie cdf chimie
ne vient il pas d'annoncer la création
d'un vapocraqueur sur la zone
industrielle cette industrie ce sera
aussi le traitement de l'aluminium donc
la création de centrales thermiques puis
de centrales nucléaires bref l'eau sera
mise à toutes les sauces toutes les
sauces du développement d'autant plus
que la population aura plus que doublé
sur ce secteur d'ici à la fin du siècle
la consommation d'eau ol aura triplé
alors il faudra envisager des solutions
nouvelles
exploiter la nappe souterraine y capter
les eaux de la hem près le vélo dans la
est stocké vervins femme sur un lac
artificiel
enfin on prévoit d'ores et déjà qu'il
faudrait faire appel à l'eau de mer
autant de problèmes aux côtés desquels
les réalités actuelles de l'exploitation
d'usinés ressemble de petites dimensions
et pourtant pour faire une tonne d'acier
une seule tonne d'acier il faut déjà
beaucoup d'eau beaucoup d'eau énormément
d'eau
[Musique]
l'industrie sidérurgique et grosses
consommatrices dont et suivant les
produits fabriqués en consomment de 100
à 200 mètres cubes à la tonne d'acier
[Musique]
les installations mises en place par
usinor pour alimenter le complexe
sidérurgique de dunkerque sont
exemplaires l'ensemble est cohérent
efficace le problème de l'eau ayant été
au premier rang des préoccupations des
promoteurs de cette opération la
proximité de la mer offrait aussi
certains avantages des avantages tentant
pourquoi en effet ne pas plus utiliser
l'eau de mer la mer véritable ressource
quasiment inépuisable réserve à
manipuler cependant avec précaution car
très vite on en fait arrivé à maltraiter
l'eau de mer de la même façon que l'on
avait maltraité d'eau douce d'expérience
du dinner est intéressante tout d'abord
parce qu'elle montre que même sans
incitations des pouvoirs publics
le problème de l'eau compte aux yeux des
industriels
pour l' agence de bassin l'expérience
est concluante car elle peut aussi
servir d'argument pouvant décider les
industriels se faisant tirer l'oreille
c'était au départ déjà un problème
important parce que la région du nord
n'est pas très riche en ressources en
eau douce et que lors de la création
d'une usine en était limitée un débit de
20 mille mètres cubes jour
comme au consommer pouvant être prises
dans la
d'autre part
diversité d utilisation nécessite t
les installations de recyclage plus ou
moins élaborés des installations de
traitement également plus ou moins
élaborée
on s'aperçoit finalement que l'on n'est
pas loin de considérer l'eau comme étant
une véritable matière première une
matière première avec laquelle il faut
compter une matière première que l'on
peut récupérer donc un élément que l'on
a tout intérêt à sauvegarder
il faut étudier le moyen de récupérer et
de recycler l'eau il faut développer
l'industrie d'abord modérément et voir
quels sont les indices qui sont
indispensables le type de l'un de ses
noms d'indispensables c'est le de
l'automobile individuelle qui ne pas se
développer inconsidérément bon mais
alors on a des usines utilisant si ce
taux si elles payent l'eau et si elles
payent le dga qu'elle porte aux rivières
parleurs d'effluents est alors déchets
elles sont amenées à prendre des mesures
pour recycler l'eau les sucreries
refroidissent les eaux et les réutilise
il faut une taxe sur l'eau qui oblige à
ce recyclage ils font une taxe sur les
pollutions qui oblige aux stations
d'épuration et à ce moment là on pourra
développer l'industrie avec les mêmes
ressources en eau qu actuellement et
sans dégrader les rivières comme on le
fait actuellement les au manque partout
parce que nous les utilisons d'une façon
inconsidérée j'ai appris à nager dans la
scarpe aux environs d'arras je ne pense
pas que les arrageois continue à se
baigner aujourd'hui 20 scarpe
[Musique]
jusqu'à présent nous n'avons considérer
l'autre comme un produit de consommation
une matière première indispensable au
développement de l'industrie cela nous a
fait complètement oublier que l'eau au
même titre que les arbres fait partie de
notre cadre de vie l'eau fait partie du
paysage de l'eau on peut tout faire la
transporter en canalisations lui faire
parcourir des centaines de kilomètres
sans servir les purs et s'en servir à
nouveau
il faut songer aussi à en faire autre
chose qu'un instrument de travail il
faut que l'eau s'intègre dans un cadre
de délassement et de loisirs
malheureusement partout on se penche sur
l'eau on s'aperçoit que sa qualité est
menacée même dans les petits coins que
l'on fréquente révol entier pendant le
week end
[Musique]
les chaînes canal modéré qui a été
creusé et s'est alimenté par quel par
les marées c'est d'ailleurs dans le
temps c'était de l'eau de source et
d'eau de pluie maintenant les égouts se
déversent un intérieur alors ça devient
d'ouvriers le plus racé d'une rupture 1
il ya quand même des poissons il ya
quand même une vieille à quoi sont elles
à peu près on en trouve un qui l'honore
tous les semaines quoi lors des cartes
comme ça l'étang gelé brême mais selon
vous le problème de l'eau c'est un
problème important s'apprend très
important parce que vous apportez quand
même toutes sortes de maladies vous
voyez vous voyez la couleur de l'eau
tout les égouts de tous les communes se
déverse à que ce soit pas lu lé couru
beaucoup c'est une facilité qui coûtera
cher aux communes un jour ou l'autre
[Musique]
dans la lutte pour la qualité de l'eau
les collectivités locales doivent
prendre une part de plus en plus
important à leur égard le rôle
d'incitation de l' agence de bassin jour
relativement bien pour une station mise
en oeuvre par une collectivité locale la
subvention est de l'ordre de 25 à 30 %
du montant total de la construction 1 ce
rôle d'incitateur vient s'ajouter un
rôle de conseiller l'agencé là pour
apporter toute l'aide technique
nécessaire dans la programmation des
travaux
dès que la réalisation d'une station et
décider c'est un petit peu la course au
près la subvention est quelque chose le
financement en est une entrée le plus
souvent on fait appel pour les prêts à
long terme à la caisse des dépôts et
consignations ou bien dans le cas de
communes rurales aux caisses de crédit
agricole
dans la lutte contre la pollution
l'action de certains groupes de pression
et déterminant les associations oeuvrant
pour la protection de la nature se sont
multipliés ces dernières années un mot
revient sur toutes les lèvres c'est un
petit peu la dernière manic de parler
d'écologie en fait il ne s'agit ni plus
ni moins que de la manifestation peut
être tardive de notre instinct de
conservation à la pointe du combat
les pêcheurs à la ligne directement
engagés dans la bataille pour la qualité
de l'eau ils agissent en véritables
gendarmes les pêcheurs vont dans pas de
calais vont dans la somme et puis un peu
dans le nord vers le littoral on dit que
les pêcheurs sont très actifs pour se
battre pour obtenir que les cours d'eau
soit de moins en moins polluer c'est une
force de pression importante je crois
est de plus en plus forte cette pression
puisque un tas de gens s'intéressent à
la question maintenant voir des
organisations comme dans leur nature
sont pour nous ce qui était impensable
il y avait un temps nous espérons que la
liste redevient rapport en 1976 si ce
que nous a dit l'avion de l' agence de
bassin était justifiée on pourrait
espérer que l'adle lorette été avec la
station d'épuration de marquette et il
hélas les espoirs des pêcheurs ont été
déçus
mais
[Musique]